hey there and welcome to this special
motion science video my name is cameron
and why is this a special video well
it's because today we are featuring a
product for after effects
from ae juice
and this is their product packs ae juice
has put together 20 000 plus animation
assets
in a hundred plus different categories
and this library is awesome so i'm going
to show you four examples here of what i
put together very very quickly using ae
juices product packs which you can see
here so in this very first example you
can see i have some time lapse footage
of some rocks in the desert some clouds
moving overhead
really cool footage
but what i can do here is i can apply
something like the vhs pack and open
this up
and you're going to see there's all
these different presets here the vhs
pack tons and tons and tons of presets
each of these packs is just like this
they're amazing so what i can do is i
can start by using a camera interface
like camera interface number four
which is also great in the previous
years that we can see
examples of the preset in motion so i
can turn on camera interface
4 and you can see here what it's adding
to the
visual here in the composition next i'm
going to add text title 10
and text title 10 is going to pop on
here at the end fbi warning so if i go
down here to text titles you're going to
see text title 10 as this fbi warning
preset
next i'm going to add a preset called
colorful
colorful is going to be found under vhs
looks we've got like bad cam one two
three four and so on bad colors
lots of different presets i picked
colorful here i thought it was pretty
cool you can see
immediately what it does to the image
next i'm gonna apply rgb blocks and
that's right here and we can see these
blocks within the image this is going to
be under i believe special effects and
yes here we go rgb blocks again i love
how the presets give you a little
animation to see what it could possibly
look like on your footage
i'm going to apply rgb blocks again so
i've got it here
this section where it's kind of cut off
and then stops here then it pops back on
here and then i'm going to apply
distortion 3 and this is under
distortions and you can see here it's a
really nice effect uh distortion three
is this one right here
really dig that but look at all these
other distortion effects you can do it's
just really cool stuff so distortion
three and then finally distortion 15
which if i scroll down here we can see
distortion 15 right here so let's take a
look here
at our finished
composite and you can see it's super
super easy to use it's super quick
fast rendering and we can go from this
basic footage like we see here
to this super stylized
composite
like we see here
next let's move on to output two second
example i've got this
rosary footage here
this is a handheld shot of a rosary
dangling in space
the first thing i applied to this one is
screen recording 01 so if i go back to
my products i'm going to go over here
and i'm going to find my camera screen
pack and screen recording 01 is right
here and it's nice you can see footage
underlying these presets so you can get
a better idea of how it may look
screen recording on once put in here
next we've got circle tunnel
this is from
the neon glitch pack right here circle
tunnel right here look at all these
awesome presets here these are just
amazing there's so much you can do with
these you can overlay them and use
transfer modes and combine them and
create all new looks yourself so circle
tunnels next then we've got aberration
this is going back to the vhs pack and i
think it's under vhs looks actually
let's go
special effects aberrations right here
one thing i do want to mention is that i
can double click these presets and i
have a controls layer that pops up so if
i scroll over here and look at my
effects
you can see i can adjust the colors i
can adjust the intensity the offset the
softness the scattering the wiggle
all of that so for a lot of these
presets you can adjust all of these
parameters it's not like you have to
apply a preset and that's it
you can apply the preset and then you
can get your own
look by tweaking the individual
parameters within the preset next we've
got colorful this is again from the vhs
pack and just look how it just makes it
so much more interesting to look at and
the last thing we have here is the line
glitch
19
which i believe is here under tape
glitches
and you can see all these different
looks here
super cool stuff line glitch 19 right
there and if i preview this one you can
see we've got just this really trippy
shot now right with these circles kind
of emphasizing this rosary hanging in
the middle screen plus our our screen
recording over the top here
uh really putting emphasis on that
rosary so really cool trippy look here
uh just with a few clicks and bringing
some presets in here
output number three here we've got some
cranes right some slow-moving footage
here of cranes
really pretty look at already colorized
already stylized i'm gonna add some
light leaks here so the first one i'm
gonna add is light leak
31 which is right here
and you're gonna see that it's set to a
screen mode and we can see there it is
so i can go go to my products here and
light leak
31 is
right here
uh and i should mention as well it's
really easy to add these so let's say i
wanted to add light leak 28 all i have
to do is double click that light leak
and what it's going to do is it's going
to
drop that light leak onto my timeline at
the position of wherever my
cursor is in the timeline so because my
cursor is here in the timeline
it's going to
drop that light lake right here and
there you can see lightly 28 is now at
this position i can easily you know drag
and
drop or reposition this any place in my
timeline that i want to
so there it is and if i want to use it i
would change it from normal to screen
and there we go looks really nice
go ahead and delete that out of here
next we've got light leak two i dropped
this here at the beginning it's a really
nice transition and i'm using color
dodge
to get the look that we see here which
is really nice next i've got 16
millimeter grain 4x3 color this is from
the film textures pack which i can see
right here
and if i scroll down here it is right
here so again i love the previews inside
of each of these presets so i can get a
very quick idea of how it's going to
look
looks awesome next light leak 46 dropped
it in there from the light leaks pack
and then noise number one
right here over the top noise number one
is from film noise and you can see here
this is the one i'm using lots of really
cool interesting visually interesting
presets here to choose from as well
so i drop those over the top
and preview this one and you can see
check that out it just looks really
awesome right it's a very stylized look
i love how the sprockets here in the
film
vignette
have some movement to them there's a lot
of just subtle movement a lot of subtle
texture throughout
really really cool elements to use
final example here is output number four
and this is one that i built uh just no
footage underneath i started with these
two scenes scene two and scene seven and
these are from the glitch kinetic
typography pack which i open up here and
you can go in here you can change the
text and all that good stuff just by
if i want to double click this one scene
two i can go into this text precomp here
and just change the type to whatever i
want it to be and that's what's going to
appear on screen versus like if i don't
want to say don't panic so i started
with these
two pieces of text don't panic and watch
out
as my base
next i added analog glitch 18
and you can see that behind there this
is from the analog glitch pack which we
can see here and just look at all the
presets here like amazing presets a lot
of different things you can play around
with and and have a lot of fun with
right these are just really cool presets
drop that in the background there analog
glitch 17 is another one i'm going to
drop it in right here of the top set it
to screen as well you can see here
what's happening with that then we've
got glitch overlay 5
and glitch overlay 5.
is from the glitch pack which we see
right here
and look at these these are awesome too
just so much fun i mean i love all the
presets there's so many presets here 20
000 plus presets so glitch overlay hue
noise is dropped in this is from the vhs
pack bad colors of three from the vhs
pack really love that pack and then
finally
glow light 03
is from that pack as well and what we
get is a really stylized
kinetic type piece
just again just dropping
a few clicks and dropping in some
presets over the top and this is what we
get so
four awesome examples
only took me
a very short amount of time to create
these
to get very stylized looks
you can get all of these preset packs 50
plus preset packs
plus online tutorials that are amazing
for a very very affordable price and i'm
telling you for the price this deal is a
steal
there are again so many presets
so many packs
you could spend days and days and days
creating with this with these elements
and for the price these presets are a
no-brainer in fact if you scroll down at
the description below you're gonna see a
couple links and by clicking those links
you're going to be helping this channel
out and you're also going to be getting
an incredible deal on all of these
presets and packs so that my friends is
what i've got for you today on this
special motion science video as always
thank you for watching and until next
time my name is cameron and this is
motion science
[Music]
you